Transcriptor: Sharon D'Amelio
Revisor: Analia Padin
Buenos días.
Como ya escucharon,
mi nombre es Nerea Guede
y les vengo a hablar de una emoción
que no a muchos nos gusta:
el miedo.
¿Cómo superarlo sin miedo?
Suena ilógico, ¿no?
Pero seamos sinceros,
¿quién no tuvo miedo alguna vez?
Todos tenemos miedo.
Tampoco es malo tenerlo.
A mí, personalmente, me gusta mucho
hablar de esta emoción.
Aunque no es una emoción tan agradable,
es bueno saber a qué le tenemos miedo.
Conocerlos es el primer paso
para poder actuar sobre ellos.
A partir de saber a qué le tenemos miedo,
podemos desarrollar el cómo superarlos.
Hablando de esta emoción,
algunos de Uds., o todos,
se estarán preguntando:
“Pero realmente ¿qué es el miedo?“.
Bueno, el miedo es una emoción de angustia
provocada por la presencia de un peligro.
El miedo es una emoción básica,
una emoción innata,
una emoción que se encarga
de preparar al cuerpo para huir.
Básicamente, sin el miedo
no habría supervivencia.
Así de sencillo.
Con el miedo nos pueden pasar
dos cosas muy sencillas.
Una: que el miedo nos paralice
y no nos deje sacar todo nuestro potencial
o todas las cosas buenas
que tenemos para decir o hacer.
O dos: el miedo nos puede hacer actuar.
Es decir, podemos ver el miedo
de cierto modo como un maestro,
porque nos ayuda a predecir
y evitar un peligro
o algo malo que pueda estar pasando.
Pero hay un problema con este miedo:
que nos puede dominar.
Sin embargo, dejarnos torturar
por un miedo que no es real
tampoco es bueno.
Por si no me entendieron,
ahí les va un ejemplo.
Supongamos que Uds. se fueron de viaje
y están en una excursión en un zoológico
y se les cruza un león enorme
y sienten miedo.
Bueno, esa es la conducta o emoción
que deberían sentir en ese momento.
Ahora, si antes de hacer este viaje
empiezan a pensar en todas las posibles
cosas malas que podrían pasarle,
las posibles amenazas
que podrías encontrarte,
y te entra miedo estando en tu casa.
Eso, ¿es coherente?
No lo creo.
Incluso hay personas
que desarrollan miedo al miedo,
lo cual es todavía peor.
El miedo es inevitable,
pero superarlo es una decisión.
Entonces, como dije anteriormente,
el miedo de cierto modo puede ser bueno
porque te ayuda a sobrevivir.
Pero hay un segundo problema
con este miedo: que a veces es irreal.
Es decir, no es real,
como el miedo hablar en público
o el miedo a que una relación se rompa.
Eso es fruto de inseguridad.
Mucha gente, o muchos
de los que estamos acá,
alguna vez pensamos:
“El miedo es de personas cobardes,
de personas que no se saben
afrontar a su vida”.
Pero les vengo a decir
que eso no es verdad,
porque el miedo, de cierto modo,
es una forma de autoprotección
ante cualquier situación de peligro,
sobre todo cuando ponemos en riesgo
nuestra integridad física.
Si sos una persona
que tiene miedo muy constantemente,
no es que esté mal,
pero lo que hay que evitar
es dejarse llevar por ese miedo
y perder el control.
Hay una frase que dice así:
“El miedo te paraliza,
te mantiene despierto,
te hace sobrevivir,
pero hay que aprender a controlarlo
porque el miedo es como el fuego
que está quemándonos por dentro.
Ahora, si controlás este fuego,
solo te calentará.
Pero si dejas que te controle, te quemará
y quemará todo lo que te rodea”.
Entonces, aprendamos
a controlar nuestros miedos.
Que no nos ganen, que no nos quemen.
Aceptá tus miedos, no los niegues.
Enfrentate a todo
lo que te hace sentir miedo.
Y la llave de todo eso
es tenerte confianza a ti mismo.
Todo lo que querés lograr
está del otro lado del miedo.
Y cuando superes estos miedos,
van a venir cosas buenas.
Vas a ganar autoestima, confianza.
Entonces, ¿qué vas a hacer con tus miedos?
¿Vas a dejar que el miedo te queme
o vas a mirarlo como un maestro,
controlarlo y superarlo?
Gracias.
(Aplausos)